let me ask you something you left new
york and
did you drive to mississippi is that
right
yeah so i was i was in new york for
three months during the uh
during when it was the worst and and
like every other person who was there
uh with me we get to a point where
you're like you know new york's not
built to
to live in your life in your house
because this is very small like my one
bedroom
i got it when i first moved here and i
was so busy i just never moved
and it is a it's a studio apartment
where someone slapped a wall in the
middle of it and was like hey
but it's a room though and so and so as
as i got here i was like i gotta get out
i got i need space i got to get out of
here but i want to do it safely as i can
so i had uh the the guy who drives me at
snl
uh i had i i was like yo could you take
me down to mississippi i know it's a
long way
but could you please take me down there
and he was like yes we took two days
a two-day trip right it took two weeks
to map out our routes where we would
stop at so
we would be safe because my dad's high
risk and i had to like get tested like
three times to make sure because i guess
the tests then were like 67
and so i was like i gotta get tested a
hundred times to know that i'm like
healthy
but we we did it we got down there and
it was just it was so much
it was so cool to have like space to
walk around like my parents house
i would just walk in the kitchen and
just walk around
i didn't even want anything i wasn't
hungry i was just walking around because
it was twirling around
i was just guys you guys have this
it was it was amazing it's weird for
people to go back
and spend a lot of time in close
quarters with their parents how do you
pass the time when you're with them
what's that like my dad likes to watch
westerns and sit
i don't think the world has changed much
for my pops uh he's like i wasn't
talking nobody no way
so i got more things than i ever had
before he likes he likes westerns
yeah i got him a fire stick and he was
like and he just learned
what binging is we just put him on
binging i i i really caught him up
with a technology man with the fire
stick he watches westerns that are so
old
they're just like not even pictures
there's just like a guy describing what
the scene is
like a guy rides in on horse and then
indian is he indian no no he's not
just a bunch of racist guys making a
movie
yeah yeah my mom she like like
loves movie night but only to just go to
bed
10 minutes into the movie oh she passes
out oh yeah
she passes out real quick and then she
wakes up and tries to guess what's
happening
she's just like oh why that man live in
a box there's no box
there's no man she's asleep she's like
half sleep watching the movie
she's always spoiling it and she doesn't
even know she's doing it she's like oh
he could kill her i could tell by his
hat
[Laughter]
but she's right though i don't
understand a genius oh she's always
right that's funny
yeah it's she's always on point it's
just like with the weirdest
i don't like the way his feet look he
definitely kidnapped her like
what that's crazy my mom's like a big
if she is up she's a big question person
like if no matter if you've seen the
movie or not she's like what's gonna
happen
i'm seeing it with you lady i don't know
but knives out of something i saw a
bunch
and so i was like looking forward to her
like trying to guess the turns
and it was like one movie she couldn't
all the way figure out and she was like
huh it was almost like she was mad at
the movie that it beat her
right she's like uh-huh